hallo und herzlich willkommen am Fliegerhorst
Hinterstoisser in Zeltweg der Heimat des
Eurofighter Taifun 2000 des österreichischen
Bundesheeres und herzlich willkommen im 21
Jahrhundert mein Name ist Patrick Wöss bin
vom Dienstgrad der Oberleutnant 30 Jahre und
ich bin einsatzpilot am System Eurofighter
ich darf euch heute auf ein Rundgang um den
Eurofighter mitnehmen schauen wie der Eurofighter
ausgestattet ist was man alles zu sehen kann wie
er funktioniert grundsätzlich dafür mal sagen zum
eurofight der ist ein Kampfflugzeug der vierten
Generation und er ist ein swing-roll Fighters
swingroll bedeutet das dass der Eurofighter
gleichzeitig in derselben Mission Luftziele
und Bodenziele bekämpfen kann es ist quasi
ein Flieger der alles kann und damit man alles
kann braucht man sehr viel Ausrüstung und diese
Ausrüstung sehen wir uns jetzt in einem Rundgang
an ist grundsätzlich ein fly bei weiherflieger
das heißt es gibt keine Steuerstange mehr wie man
sich das vorstellt der Pilot ist mit Steuerknüppel
nicht mehr Star mit den Steuerflächen verbunden
das heißt der Computer oder der Flieger wird nur
noch durch Computer gesteuert Eurofighter ist im
unterschallbereich ein sehr labiles Flugzeug das
braucht auch damit mit meinem Luftkampf schnell
um die Kurve kommen und damit wir da siegreich
hervorgehen im transsonischen Bereich zwischen
sprich im Bereich um mach eins um die einfache
Schallgeschwindigkeit wird er dann indifferent und
im Überschall ist er dann sehr stabil das brauchen
wir folgen wenn man lange Strecken zurücklegen
und sehr sehr hoch fliegen und jetzt schauen wir
uns an wie der Flieger des macht und was wir
dazu brauchen aufgrund der hohen Agilität des
Fliegers und der reinen hergehen denn Labilität
ist es für den Flieger sehr sehr wichtig dass
immer weiß wie hoch das er ist wie schnell das
ist und wo er ist Aufschluss darüber gibt den
Flight Control Computer sprich den Computer der
den Flieger aktiv steuerbar hält und stabil hält
diese Geräte hier das sind die sogenannten Edits
die eher data transducer der Arbeiter hat vier
davon und nimmt aus der Luft alle Daten die er
braucht das bleibt Kontrollsystem spricht das
System das dem Flieger am Fliegen hält ist
vierfach Redundanz ist quadrupel redundant
besteht aus vier Computern und wir können drei
Computer ausfallen und der Flieger fliegt immer
noch also es ist sehr sehr resistent gegenüber
Ausfallserscheinungen des Weiteren sehen wir
hier gleich nach vorne die triebwerkseinlässe wir
haben zwei Triebwerke zwei eurojet Triebwerke mit
jeweils 55 Kilo Newton Schub und der Möglichkeit
noch den Nachbrenner zu zünden der Nachbrenner
nichts anderes wie das der Flieger viel viel mehr
Leistung bekommt wir kommen dann vor 55 Kilonewton
auf 90 Kilonewton zusammen mal zwei 18 Tonnen
Schub man kann sich das so vorstellen wie war
mein Auto sitzt das Gaspedal ganz durch und auf
einmal doppelt so viel PS und damit man es ist
besser vorstellen kann unsere straßenbes von den
Triebwerken werden ungefähr 150.000 Auto pS Das
ist sehr sinnvoll für Kampf für das dass ich Höhen
schnell erreiche und das brauchen wir vor allem in
der täglichen Überwachung dass wir eventuelle
zielluftfahrzeuge schnell interpretieren sprich
schnell beamtshandeln können so die Triebwerke
wir können 5 Tonnen Sprit im Flieger mitnehmen
der Flieger hat ungefähr 11 Tonnen als Lehre
er kann maximal 23,5 Tonnen schwer werden bis
5 Tonnen internen Kraftstoff haben wir dann nur
siebeneinhalb Tonnen zur Verfügung welcher wir auf
den Flieger als Außenlasten draufhängen können in
Form von maßstabkörper intelligenten Bomben sprich
cederms Mittelstreckenraketen Kurzstreckenraketen
und natürlich die Bordkanone und diese schauen
wir uns in weiterer Folge an an der linken Seite
des Rumpfes befindet sich unsere Maschinenkanone
seine integrierte 27mm Kanone wir haben 150 Schuss
mit und die kadenzzahl ungefähr 30 Schuss in der
Sekunde das heißt die Kanone schießt sehr sehr
schnell das brauchen wir vor allem um Ziele im
luftkampfbekämpfen zu können des Weiteren haben
wir an der Unterseite des Flugzeuges sprich
an den Tragflügel als auch am Bälle am Bauch des
Fliegers 13 Aufhängepunkte für diverse Außenlasten
die wir transportieren können gesagt das ist
angefangen von Marschflugkörper über Raketen
Bomben bis hin zu aussentanks wir haben fünf
Tonnen Sprit innen und können nochmal zwei Tonnen
Kraftstoff an den außenlaststationen tragen diese
möglichst uns eine Flugzeit von über 3 Stunden
hier auf der linken Seite sehen Sie den itzpel
sehr kompliziert an ist es aber nicht ist einfach
eine Aufhängung für die Hauptbewaffnung
in unserer friedenszeitlichen luftrömung
Überwachung nämlich den airpolising sie ist die
Iris t ein Hitze Suchende Waffe ein infrared
imaging system telefressed das heißt man kann
sie das vorstellen wie bei topgun jetzt waren
der fliegt und der hört seinen Ton wenn er den
Gegner bekämpfen will das ist genau diese Waffe
das heißt ich brauche einen Ton der Suchkopf
braucht einen Ton und danach trifft er auch
weiters ist auf diesem Kitzbühel sind unsere
Gegenmaßnahmen montiert wenn man unten rein schaut
dann können wir noch an dann reinschauen sind die
sogenannten Chefs installiert Chefs sind nichts
anderes wie Aluminium Beutel die ausgestoßen
werden von uns die haben dieselbe Radarsignatur
wieder Flieger und schützen uns davor von
radarwaffen getroffen zu werden weiter innen
haben wir noch Flair Aufhängungen Flairs sind
gegen Hitze Suchende Raketen das haben Phosphor
Kugeln die wir auch auf Befehl ausstoßen können
die die ähnliche oder dieselbe Hitze Signatur
haben wie die Triebwerke von Flieger und somit
die feindlichen Raketen täuschen können weiters
haben wir am rechten winktipp nämlich hier drinnen
die Kreis nennt man das das enttäuscht Körper die
wir ausstoßen können die dann mit einem Seil am
Flieger nachgezogen werden und ein zweites Ziel
simulieren das heißt wir sind damit fähig eine
Waffe abzulenken die kommen hier hinten raus wir
ziehen Sie ein paar Meter paar 100 Meter hinter
uns her und die Rakete wird damit getäuscht zum
ausstoßen der Flairs sprich ist zuerst der
Chefs die schmeißen wir hier raus spricht
gegen radarwaffen verteidigen wir uns hiermit oder
hiermit und gegen Infrarot Suchende Waffen haben
wir die ausschlussöffnungen da unten genau beim
Fahrrad weiterhin wie gesagt 13 Aufhängepunkte wir
haben supersonic fuel tanks das heißt wir können
auch mit den Außenlasten in den überall gehen das
ist für den Flieger überhaupt kein Problem
aufgrund der enormen Stärke der Triebwerke
und deren dynamischen Eigenschaften ist es in den
Überschall gehen ganz ganz einfach es ist für uns
tatsächlich nur eine Zahl es passiert im Cockpit
relativ wenig der Flieger greift gleich das
aufgrund seiner Sensoren und mit den Computern aus
dass wir uns permanent ein angenehmes Fluggefühl
entsteht das Gute ist auch wir sitzen vor den
Schall das heißt wir hören den überall Knall
nicht als nächstes befinden wir uns am Leitwerk
grundsätzlich haben wir hier den Exhaus der
Triebwerke das heißt hier wird einfach die heiße
Luft nachdem sie verbrannt ist wieder ausgestoßen
des Weiteren befinden sich hier hinten drinnen
unser Fallschirm unser Bremsschirm ehrlicherweise
und unser Fanghaken der Eurofighter kann auf
verschiedene Arten zum Stillstand gebracht
werden natürlich beim Landen mit den will bricks
sprich mit dem Bremsen wie man es vom Auto gewöhnt
ist dass man einfach in die Bremsen steigt und der
Flieger wird langsamer die zweite Möglichkeit ist
dass wir hier einen Bremsschirm auswerfen da geht
dann hinterm Flieger auf und funktioniert quasi
wie ein Fallschirm nur in der horizontalen Ebene
und dritte ist hier unten ist ein Haken drauf wir
haben in Zeltweg zwei fangkabeln das heißt wir
können mit dem Eurofighter so landen wie ein
Kampfjet auf einem flugzeugträgerland ist kommt
ein Haken herunter wir gehen ins Seil und stehen
dann innerhalb von wenigen Metern auf der linken
Seite des Fliegers schauen wir uns jetzt noch
einmal genau unsere Steuerflächen an aufgrund der
aerodynamischen Eigenschaften als delta-flügler
ist der Eurofighter nicht so aufgebaut werden
normales Flugzeug wie man es vielleicht kennt
den Passagierflugzeug zum Beispiel der Eurofighter
hat eine finde ein Seitenleitwerk über dem wir uns
über die Hochachse stabilisieren das heißt der
Flieger wird zum Gehirn gebracht des Weiteren
haben wir kein Höhenleitwerk der Flieger
hat hier an den Tragflächen hinterseiten
zwei Klappen montiert die fungieren gleichzeitig
als höhenruderquerruder und als Landeklappen das
heißt der Flieger der Flight Control Computer und
ich einen Input gebe zum Beispiel ich möchte nach
rechts Rollen suchte der Flieger die Steuerflächen
aus der gerade dazu braucht und steuert diese an
auf der linken Seite befindet sich auch noch
unser ECM Pot hört sich wieder kompliziert an
da ist sie einfach diese electronic Counter
Messer Pot das heißt er beschützt uns vor
Gefahren im elektromagnetischen Spektrum dieses
Gerät schafft es andere Flugzeuge zu täuschen
das heißt wir kommen in einen Vorteil er kann
falsche Ziele projizieren da kann das stören
und so weiter je nachdem was für eine Datenbank
geladen ist und was wir vorhin von ihm wollen so
unterstützt uns dieser bot gut weiter von unserem
isynt geht es über die linke Vorderseite des
Flugzeuges hin zum Cockpit grundsätzlich gleich
die linke Seite der rechten Seite abgesehen von
den Link Tipps identisch an den Vorderseiten
der Tragflächen haben wir sogenanntes letzte
helfen uns dabei mehr auftritt zu erzeugen und
auch im Kurvenradius enger zu werden falls wir
das benötigen wir haben ein dreipunktfahrwerk
ist das der Eurofighter sitzt immer auf dem
Hauptfahrwerk auf und senkt dann erst das Buch
Fahrwerk ab des Weiteren sieht man hier am belli
eingemacht gewisse Ausnehmungen von denen haben
wir vier Stück hier würde eine Allwetter Waffe
Platz haben wenn wir diese benötigen würden
als nächstes bevor wir in den Arbeitsplatz
des Piloten kommen nämlich ins Cockpit gehen wir
noch kurz über die Ausrüstung eines Eurofighter
Piloten drüber bis ihr seht stehe ich nicht im
normalen fluchtdienstanzug für euch sondern ich
brauche relativ viel Zusatzausrüstung aufgrund
von der Geschwindigkeiten der gehkräfte die auf
mich wirken und der Höhe damit im Eurofighter bei
Bewusstsein und am Leben bleibe bei Eurofighter
kann grundsätzlich bis weit in die Stratosphäre
vordringen sprich wir befinden uns hier in der
Troposphäre und eine Atmosphärenschicht drüber
bis dorthin können wir mit Eurofighter fliegen
wir brauchen daher sehr viel versorgt und die
Versorgung basiert durch unser aja das Air Crew
Equipment des simply wir sind damit mit dem
Flieger verbunden bekommen durch die diversen
Schläuche und Anschlüsse alles was wir zum
Überleben brauchen sprich Druckluft Atemluft und
Strom für die gesamte Ausrüstung von unten nach
oben stecke ich in einer gehose an die g-hose hat
diesen Grund dass der Eurofighter auf +9 bis -3g
beschleunigen kann plus 9g kann man sie etwas so
vorstellen so wie wir zum Boden stehen haben wir
eingehe die einfache erdanzierungskraft das heißt
ich mit meiner Ausrüstung habe ungefähr 100 Kilo
wenn ich jetzt zum Flieger anziehe im Kurven im
Flug z.B beschleunige auf +9g das heißt ich werde
9 mal so schwer ich wiege dann fast eine Tonne bei
diesem Belastungen bewegt sich alles was im Körper
nicht fest verankert ist sprich alles außer die
Knochen Richtung unten das blöde ist das auch das
Blut aus dem Gehirn rausfließt und da das Gehirn
ohne Blut nicht arbeiten kann wäre es von Vorteil
wenn das Gehirn dort bleibt dafür haben wir
die Hose bei anliegender Beschleunigung schnürt
diese g-hose meine Beine ab und drückt mir in den
Bauchraum hinein wobei meine Muskeln von alleine
aus Reflex angespannt werden somit wird eine
Barriere erstellt und das Blut kann nicht mehr die
Beine versacken Weiteren haben wir die Weste an
die sie erzeugt einen Druck auf den Brustkorb
aus demselben Prinzip wir haben dann aber
unsere lebensausrüstungen drinnen ist erklären wir
euch gerne in einem anderen Video und was wir uns
auch noch sehr wichtig ist wir haben Cockpit
jetzt keinen Schreibtisch oder sonst irgendwas
wir können uns quasi kein Buch irgendwo hinlegen
drum haben wir unser Büro auf den kniebrettern mit
hier haben wir sämtliche Informationen drinnen
die vielleicht im Flug brauchen könnte sprich
diverse Anflugverfahren diverse zahlen die für
diverse Taktiken benötige bis hin zu Wirbel
warnings die irgendwann aufsagen muss wenn ihr
eine Amtshandlung in der Luft vornehme da wir
beide in der Stratosphäre fliegen und dort der
Luftdruck einfach zu gering ist für Menschen dass
der dabei Bewusstsein bleiben kann bzw Bewusstsein
kann er bleiben ja aber er ist geistig wie ein
Kleinkind müssen wir beatmet werden vom Flieger
und dies geschieht über die Sauerstoffmaske in
unserem Helm wir haben ein eigenes System im
Flieger das ist onboard oxygeneration System
das heißt der Flieger erzeugt für uns Sauerstoff
und verabreicht die uns dann in einer atembahn
Luft mit der exakten luftdichte und damit wir
bei Bewusstsein bleiben genug zur Ausrüstung
jetzt schauen wir uns den Arbeitsplatz eines
Eurofighter Piloten nämlich das Cockpit genau an
gut herzlich willkommen im copit des Eurofighters
diese Sets ist der Eurofighter ein single-siedler
das heißt wir befinden uns alleine im Flugzeug
wir haben kein Fluglärm mit jeder ist für seinen
Flieger selbst verantwortlich man muss sich quasi
auf sich selbst verlassen zum Cockpit Design ist
eher sechs ist der Steuerknüppel relativ riesig
der Flieger ist grundsätzlich auf ein Hot das
Prinzip aufgebaut das heißt hands on Trottel
in Stick ich kann den gesamten Flieger alle
wichtigen Sachen die ich im Luftkampf brauche
Steuern einfach nur über den kontrollstick und
dem Leistungshebel hat den Grund dass man wie
gesagt bis 9 g erreichen können und ob ungefähr
2G kann man nicht mehr die Gliedmaßen lassen sich
nicht mehr heben weil es einfach zu schwer werden
es muss sich das quasi alles was ich brauche für
den Luftkampf so erreichen dass ich meine Hände
nicht mehr bewegen muss nicht mehr heben muss vom
Cockpit Layout wir haben drei MSDS das place das
heißt wir nehmen unsere Informationen die wir
fürs Fliegen brauchen von den drei Bildschirmen
herum und unser Hauptinstrument ist das head up
Display das ist diese Scheibe hier kannst du das
Vorstellen man sieht die gesamte Welt einfach nur
grün hinterlegt mit sämtlichen Daten die gerade
für meinen Flug brauche natürlich sitzen wir auch
im Eurofighter Cockpit nicht auf einen normalen
Sitz sondern auf einem Schleudersitz ich befinde
mich hier auf dem Martin bakersitz das ist ein
sogenannter 00-sitz der schleudersitzer quasi die
Möglichkeit dass wenn ich mich im Boden Nähe mit
90 Grad Querlage aus dem Flieger rausschießen
würde würde mich der Sitz retten das heißt ich
würde es überleben sind sehr intelligenter Sitz
wir haben Arm entlegress trains das heißt der Sitz
fängt uns fängt unsere Gliedmaßen ein und fixiert
sie am sitzen das hat folgenden Hintergrund wir
können mit dem Eurofighter über 2000 km/h schnell
werden ungefähr 2500 km/h die Zweieinhalbfache
Schallgeschwindigkeit jeder hat schon mal beim
Auto bei 50 60 km/h vielleicht die Hand aus dem
Fenster gehalten und da gemerkt dass es sehr
ungut ist mit Luftzug war nicht sonder km/h vor
ist es wichtig unangenehme tut beizeiten wie man
kann sich vorstellen was bei zweieinhalbtausend
km/h mit den Gliedmaßen passieren würde des
Weiteren haben wir am Schleudersitz eine EUB
nennen wir das eine auxilery oxygen bottle
das heißt wenn man kleine Sauerstoffflasche
mit durch das wir also extreme Höhen erreichen
können Kinder wird dort die Umgebungsluft nicht
warten das heißt wir müssen versorgt werden
bis dass wir in eine Sauerstoff oder in eine
luftdichtere Atmosphärenschicht gefallen sind
und dort kann sie dann der Schleudersitz sprich
der Fallschirm entfachen und bremst dann
unseren Fall und wir kommen gut am Boden an
falls ihr Interesse habt beim Bundesheer Pilot
zu werden vom Eurofighter benutzt zu werden dann
meldet euch an der angegebenen Adresse unten denn
Eurofighter fliegen beim Bundesheer ist wie Top
Gun nur viel cooler und jetzt nehme ich Euch mit
auf einen Trainingsflug quer durch die Republik